her hair part is your hair part it's
coming from right above her ear okay
well we're obviously meant to be
together Matt I completely agree with
you we are meant to be together how can
we deny our compatible hairlines
slide into my DMs this is me shooting my
shot my DMs are open for you in public I
have an autoimmune disease called
ulcerative colitis it's very similar to
Crohn's disease no no yeah I know yeah
um I've had to get I had to get my large
intestine removed when I was 13. sorry
to hear it um and it is a big factor in
my life
um is that something as far as dating
goes is that something that would make
you apprehensive to date someone if they
have pre-existing medical conditions I
just tell people when I'm going on dates
I just tell people that's right yeah
because
if you can't deal with it then that's
not going to work Matt can't wait to
hear from you in my DMs I actually was
thinking about this the other day
because they someone called in on Golden
hour and did the same uh asked this ass
something uh somebody had something not
that but they were like when do I tell
oh a kid it was a kid that STD and um
and a kid had an STD no I'm just kidding
that's the STD you get oh oh yes
hilarious joke I would have gotten it if
I wasn't a little bit sick yeah oh okay
that's okay yeah and you would have
laughed regular not that way because you
don't laugh that regularly right yeah
exactly so anyway
um yeah the uh you know well something
like that I think you don't have to
bring up first date no no but that's
also not the question the question is
yeah I know the met we as men I know the
question well go ahead and answer it I'm
saying first of all my thing would we
and then okay so then what is she I
would not I would not I would let love
lead yeah if you I mean I actually think
it's like it's sort of the inverse of
a red flag like like emotional
or psychological damage is much more
concerning than some kind of like
internal physical damage oh yeah like
and in that I don't if I really loved
someone fell in love with especially if
I just like met someone fell in love
with them and I found out they had
ulcerative colitis I would not
okay well what do we have to do to make
it to where you're comfortable and
everything is okay and like we take care
of you yeah make me a part of making
your life better yeah 100 whatever I can
do I would too and and a lot of people
are like that I think yeah I think most
any guy who's like it doesn't matter how
much I like a girl if she had all sort
of colitis she's gone well hey that guy
is
a [__]
loser and your piece what is that oh
piece of [__] yeah yeah that's horrible
yeah loser piece of [__] and also like
what are you like that's like an actual
psychopath move because there's like no
feeling yeah yeah of actual feelings of
love it's just like this completely
superficial dumb thing all sort of
colitis I'm not too clear on what it is
but I know yeah she got her intestine
removed large intestine she said yeah
which means she just got to go potty way
quicker after she eats right it also
means there's way more room in there for
you know what disgusting just the most
disgusting you've ever been on he's got
a big old Winky
she might be for you yeah if you got a
big old what are you doing well you
don't so you shouldn't hit her no I have
a big Winky
I have a big wing all right trying to
get around the YouTube yeah I
I like if Kristen had something like
that I wouldn't even know everything
would be the same except for I would be
concerned about it I want to help and
she would be in pain more often well
everything will be the same in the
relationship oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
anyway uh well yeah my sympathy goes out
to you for having that but any guy if
you get any whiff of any guy being like
tripping having trepidation because of
that guy's a [__] loser yeah
psychological damage it's psychological
[__] is way worse usually people with
physical symptoms or physical uh
ailments ailments also have more
psychological [__] up [__] because
they have to deal with them they don't
know how to but you seem a very good uh
see I think the almost the opposite
because they have to deal with it yeah
and then they overcome it they've gotten
to this point so far and they've like
persevered you're right people go
through physical [__] at a young age it
really changes them you're right dude
grow up yeah you're right dude it
changes and I can admit when I'm wrong
oh okay but it's not even really that I
was wrong so stop yelling is what I'm
gonna say yeah I was just kind of
feeling it out I was as I was talking
and then you kind of helped with that
okay well I'm glad I could be of service
to you but yeah it makes yeah yeah yeah
okay
first I can just stop talking okay so I
can just so I can just finish doing this
uh yeah it makes you
be
that much more of an appealing potential
partner because you are more likely to
have your [__] together upstairs than
your average person even so it's
actually a plus and if guys are not
thinking of it that way then they stupid
especially because they're not realizing
they got extra room in there for God
okay man that's so not true you know
they're mystery so not true like oh
about the doctor was like but there is
an upside you know what I mean have you
ever heard of a large Winky
hello hello hello hello
[Music]